foreign
ERS De Blasio's wife's on the market get
that Coco son
yeah did you see that was he getting
divorcedure
McRae are separating a couple they're
separating they're dating other people
but they're not getting divorced sold
themselves as a political team when de
Blasio was elected nearly 10 years ago
remember when nobody was allowed to
dance in Times Square because of covid
but he was dancing with his wife in
Times Square with during covert holy
[__] remember that no nobody was allowed
but they still let nurses go and [__]
too remember that yeah they also fired
nurses remember when he sat there eating
a Shake Shack Burger saying this could
be yours if you inject an experimental
drug in you that is [__] sideways
Nets hat
CBS 2 political reporter Marsha Kramer
joining us now with uh why this
relationship is uh I wish it was Michael
Richards and he would say the stuff that
he was saying on that club about his
ex-wife
yeah like I understand reporting on this
it's obviously News why do we gotta have
a whole Round Table discussion
afterwards not a round table a CBS
approved table but isn't that weird to
be like all right yeah you should go
yeah you know de Blasio separate from
his wife for 15 years we wish him the
best do you move on and now like with
more on how that relationship's going to
affect it's not it's not going to affect
anybody well he's not an elected
official anymore so it's not affecting
anything and his daughter's all types
have already [__] up yeah it's fine
you don't have to have a discussion his
daughter is [__] weird dude yeah
flashing her [__] fur burger on the
goddamn Subway
might be my least favorite word for
[__] I don't know I mean there's a lot
of them that are bad but first but I
specifically used it because hers was
gross oh no I know it's very funny use
specific like you know what I mean like
I would never use that to refer to like
somebody's nice [__] no no but if it's
gross if it's a nice [__] it's a snitch
slacked a raccoon with a field Hatchet
a nice snapper
well Dana and Dick when building blocks
they won't fire me even though I can't
do my job anymore
just get the bronze tablets and read
them and [__] make this [__] turn
back into sand yeah I have to imagine
she must be a lovely lady for them to
have just not dumped her by now no I
think they're afraid they've just been
there forever they're worried about an
hism fast suit
Burgas mayor he made it clear that New
Yorker is getting a twofer a new
political power couple who would work
together to end what they called A Tale
of Two Cities ironically it seems the
stresses of their political life took
its toll on their we've always said it
that he just married her to so he could
become the mayor and look like he was
diverse and win they never really loved
each other I mean we've always known
that yeah let's grow up reunion I think
de Blasio is a gay guy that's my opinion
I could be wrong but I have a feeling de
Blasio the way he talks the way he acts
the way he dresses the way he sucks dick
leads me to believe that he's a
homosexual it's mostly the dick sucking
stuff I mean yeah the last thing uh
ronstein Virgie did one thing right
heroin no he didn't do it that right
he's still around
Andy did it on the left arm yeah right
oh no that's the gay arm
s
am I right man leave me alone hey I'm
gonna pierce my nipples which one is the
gay one I'm only doing one was the left
nipple or the right nipple what's the
game yes
he said that like okay he was pierced
from one nipple I'm only piercing one
nipple what's the game nipple I want to
know
um
why is he dressed in skinny jeans it's
really out of Blasio dresses Fazio
suitcase in tow left his Park Slope home
this morning he looks like a European
tourist in Sunny Isles like he's what
he's dressed like he just left Aventura
yeah yeah yeah exactly he's not even
wearing socks exactly yeah right and
then he's gonna go to the pool and be in
a speedo as news broke down yes do I
have Charlene McRae we're going their
separate ways he wasn't thrilled that a
cbs2 cameraman asked him to comment yeah
yeah but yeah it probably wouldn't be
either I mean I don't like Bill de
Blasio and I'm not defending him but
it's like yeah if I just was in the
middle of divorce and I was trying to
just get my car packed and go to work
today and I'm surrounded by camera
people going why did your wife leave you
first thing in the morning I'd be a
little I'd be a little short with them
too I tell you what maybe you're right
but you know here's the thing
considering he was the guy that was
making everyone go show me your papers
if you want a croissant I don't care
good for him no no no no no no you're
missing my point I am more than happy
with people harassing him what I'm not
happy with is them being shocked that he
would be annoyed is my point like please
keep harassing the man I love it it's
just funny to me that they go he didn't
seem too happy that CBS was in his face
in the morning yeah if I was getting a
divorce the first thing I saw in the
morning why is your wife leaving you
loser you're like hey can you [__]
leave me alone man and then and then
after and then and then after he gets
mad she goes it's probably that attitude
you have comment yeah now I can see why
your wife's leaving you [__] that would
be awesome imagine that that would be
[__] awesome Chuck Norris Gun Club de
Blasio what if
laughs
I need the newspaper de Blasio referring
to an interview he and Charlene gave to
the New York Times where they said it
was politics that created fissures in
the marriage why you literally agreed on
everything the pressures of being mayor
everything was this overwhelming
schedule this sort of series of tests
right remember oh did you think that
being the mayor of New York City was
just going to be a easy breezy job and
then you decided to also marry a black
woman come on
remember when he shut everything down
but they opened the gym just for him and
when they question him how come you can
work out of no one else kind of goes
well I have to stay in shape because I'm
the mayor and everyone wanted to murder
him yes he was he was bro he made people
like Miss the days of Bloomberg yeah it
was bad I made soda illegal I mean just
to tell you how bad this guy was
sit all the times and that sort of
people blank Black Market Coca-Cola
because they don't want to [__] get
taxed through the roof
I remember it was like it was the size
thing it was science again anything over
like 20 ounces of soda it was like so
everybody's like so large sodas at any
restaurant now just none you're not
allowed took away a little bit of our
soul add to that the failed presidential
bid that Chilean was skipped oh my God
he ran for president I completely forgot
to go about and then the code yeah
remember he ran on taking guns away
which didn't work out that never works
it made me emotionally very needy he
said and we were not as connected and
the picture of de Blasio leaving home by
himself for a trip a newly dark hairdo
matching oh God he dyed his hair I just
caught it that's a shoe polish hairdo
holy [__] and looks really bad they
even she even brought it up she was even
Throwing Shade holy [__] I should have
caught that remember he was just a white
haired dude look at his hair now getting
the car watching a picture of de Blasio
leaving home by himself for a trip a
newly dark hairdo met that is a little
shade that is Giuliani hair dye in there
dude she really did just throw him under
the bus huh nearly darkened hairdo
looking like a divorced dad
color of his shirt makes sense this is
going on trip he'll be back the couple
who married 29 years ago the groom and
bride may kiss planned a split as
unconventional as their marriage wow
that kiss was even even 29 years ago
look at the kiss
that's a gay guy kissing a woman it's
unconventional as their marriage he told
she
was the first time he's leaned down that
far
no that is definitely not the first time
he's leaned down that far it just wasn't
with a woman first time he sent him with
a woman
um look look see look what his hair used
to be tall she was short he is white she
is black she he called he dyed his hair
black so you could remember every time
he looked in the mirror he had
identified as a lesbian
wait what
wait what what wait what hold on
[__] what did I just hear let's back
it up I'm backing up I'm backing up I'm
backing up it's their marriage he was
tall she was short he is white she is
black she had identified as a lesbian
Bill de Blasio is a gay guy
he's got to be but here's why this is a
typical hag relationship where she's a
lesbian and she wanted to make it
politically and he's a gay dude and he
wanted to make it politically and they
both had one of these sham marriages she
identified as a lesbian and Bill Bill De
Blasio's Charisma turned her around or
maybe he's just looks he acts and looks
like a lesbian I don't know
uh that's a little odd as she used to
yeah that's so you're both gay yeah
Karen sent me fast food in politics is
just these fake gay couples yeah
they say for now they will live together
in their Park Slope Brownstone and date
other people after working out a set of
rules I hope that we can be a model for
how couples can communicate honestly
about what their needs are yeah
and how to conduct themselves when they
find it's a time to move they're
separated though go move to another plot
house now hey
when one of them brings someone home and
the other one has to like leave that's
gonna go great
hey Bill can you go to the gym for like
a couple hours
excellent she says they don't plan to go
to Jim's house he's fine with it oh yeah
I'll go stay with Frank with Frank Lutz
I heard that he's into that kind of
stuff uh Karen sent me flat said who's
gay de Blasio Como or frozen nah I meant
I mean the Asians that have different
pink culture it's not Frozen's fault she
says they don't plan to leave the public
Arena as they work on just what their
post Gracie Mansion life will look like
not gay what wrong show no no yeah it's
different show
we just hold on look at their beautiful
family
what a beautiful family
what a lovely family they are it's so
funny too it's like anything I'm amazed
how many people have Milano kids and
think like remember the Stewie Griffin
thing and the great thing is when I grow
up I'll be accepted by everyone
and it's like your kid's not gonna grow
up like if you're the white parent
you're the parent your kid is not going
to identify with down the road
like if I had a son with an afro like
that right is he gonna relate more than
me or is he gonna relate more to some
black chick I knocked up right
uh in the chat armor Doge yeah but he's
Italian so he's black too here's the
thing armador she's not hold on hold on
but here's the thing arm of those he's
not Italian his real name is Warren
Wilhelm Jr he kept his ex-wife's last
name because it was more electable in
the city yeah yeah exactly he's not that
that's like probably that to me was like
the the first like red flag that people
should have seen
X
what not this wife his other wife's last
name de Blasio he kept up the Blasio
Parts dropped the Wilhelm part and he
was his name was Warren Warren didn't
sound too Guido enough so he changed the
bill so it's Bill de Blasio
we're morons and we deserve the system
we have oh yeah I agree like we just
want to be able to continue our lives as
public people which it seems like we we
never stop being public people no matter
what
um but do in a way that that shows that
that you know all that we had all that
we built doesn't just go away
well after cbs2 cameraman Greg so I've
been caught up with de Blasio the former
mayor tweeted out a picture of the two
with their arms around each other he
said quote even at this moment of change
this is a love story dick and Dana okay
hold it a second oh Dana's not having
hold on Dana's not having it Dana's like
hold up a second hold on wait wait I
think Dana's team is held on let's hear
what Dana say Dana's not having it oh
that was your Dana okay hold it a second
so
some people might be going why is this a
story secondly some people might be
going
what is the positioning here of what
they're saying for any possible future
for either one of them in politics well
I think it's a story because he was in
people's homes for two years during
covert every single day and people came
to realize that he was a part of their
lives during a very difficult time and
who knows what they're doing they're
part of making their lives very
difficult is the way that stands New
Yorkers lie to each other because every
time something every time something bad
happens in New York these stupid [__]
[__] New Yorkers always be like no
people couldn't stab you show us the
city as great it's a why it's a big
apple no it's a murder rate it's a
murder rate and they're punching Asians
heads off it's not Charming anymore it's
not even Ghostbusters Charming New York
anymore it's of crime-ridden hell hole
filled with a bunch of shawarma places
and [__] rat piss
yeah yeah this isn't Fun New York where
like you know there was some crazy stuff
that went on like hey you know the crazy
hey yo Naked Cowboy how Wild is that but
it was that was endearing you know a guy
in his underwear playing a guitar now
they're [__] kidding people over the
head with [__] bricks
when you see pictures of it and there
were barely even any buildings standing
anymore right exactly like
like dude
it was New York where there was you know
I had some crime and stuff but you know
I was like hey but there was also like
people break dancing in the Subways and
now they're just [__] killing
everybody and there's and they're
melting Walgreens plastic things to
steer [__] black hair product
yeah and now there is a river of slime
flowing under New York but it's made of
[__] polyvinyl chloride it really is
and it's in your drinking water and
there's rats swimming in it the only
time anybody flails around in the
Subways when somebody's being choked out
then the only time we're actually
[__] uh enforcing laws is when we're
locking up the guy that choked him out I
know seriously or arresting a bodegaon
if we're defending himself against the
violent criminal or if the guy had a fun
cat dancing cat display in the subway
entertaining people they go to jail well
he shouldn't have stabbed that guy with
the knife he didn't bring remember that
time
for feeding homeless people yes remember
the time they addressed a guy for a gun
charge for taking the criminal's gun and
then defending himself with it
[Laughter]
King God damn
Ed up that guy's gun he tried to kill
you with you know how you have in a
legal contract oh my God and I know it's
[__] but no hey Broadway
Tom Ross Mercedes Jesus that reported
okay she sounds like uh she's on the
smack and immersed at least 70s NYC had
42nd street and punk disco clubs that's
right it's 70s New York without cpgb
that's what it is you don't even get the
cool stuff at 70s New York bro
yeah but well the cool stuff with 70s
New York was all a [__] you know
symptom of how [__] up New York was
right yeah I don't know if we want to
bring back 42nd Street like I don't mind
the [__] music venues but we don't
need a bunch of porno theaters in Times
Square okay oh I'm sorry would you
rather have a bunch of [__] trans
people reading it at least they were
centered in one area now they're in the
schools reading kids books
no I I got them I want them pushed back
off the brink of society I don't even
want them to have an area anymore
they've they've blown that opportunity
they we gave him a spot and we gave him
a spot and they didn't accept it sorry
Jewish pornographers we literally gave
you New York's Disney and yes it wasn't
enough it's redundant when you say that
um